-Holy moly!
Whoa! Whoa!
It is so great to be here!
Wow!
I feel -- I feel so light.
I feel free.
It's like --
It's like I just
took my weighted blanket off,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
Hoo!
I love the weighted blanket.
I don't know if you guys are
into that, but, oh, man.
It's a blanket
that literally depresses you.
[ Laughter ]
It's so nice
to have something to blame
for why you can't get up.
[ Light laughter ]
This blanket just holds you
in place, holds you down.
It goes,
"It's my fault tonight,"
and you go,
"Thank you, blanket."
[ Laughter ]
They say
you're supposed to calculate
10% of your body weight.
That's how heavy
your blanket's supposed to be.
But I didn't do the math.
I know myself.
I have the depression
of a much larger person,
and I want to get crushed, okay?
[ Laughter ]
I want to feel like the bed's
sleeping on me.
[ Light laughter ]
I got a 20-pounder.
Not to brag, but...
[ Light laughter ]
It's good.
I used to go to the gym
and lift 20-pound weights.
Now I just wait
until I have to pee
and fight the blanket off of me.
[ Laughter ]
You don't get laid
under a weighted blanket.
[ Laughter ]
You all knew that.
Just a little
public-service announcement.
I don't know
if there's anyone here
who has both a weighted blanket
and a partner.
Might be kind of a small center
of the Venn diagram, but...
[ Laughter ]
You gotta try, you know?
I try.
My fiancé comes home,
and I'm like,
"Peel the sandbag off of me."
[ Laughter ]
"Don't you want to see
what kind of corpse
is steaming under here?"
[ Laughter ]
It's a pretty tough sell,
you know?
'Cause even if he wanted to take
the weighted blanket off me,
he'd still have to get
the night guard out of my mouth.
[ Laughter ]
It's a whole process, you know?
It's a striptease.
That's what I'm doing.
The weighted blanket comes off,
the night guard pops out,
you take off the eye mask,
you take out the ear plugs,
you take off the snore strip --
rip!
You leave the humidifier on.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah!
'Cause you don't
want to get dry.
Right, fellas?
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Do we have any
night-guard wearers here?
[ Cheers ]
Yeah?
Are you clenching,
or are you grinding?
-Both!
-Both! Me, too!
We're furious!
Isn't that fun?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, man.
If you don't know what
a night guard is,
it's kind of like the
mouth piece you wear for hockey
if the hockey's in your mind.
[ Laughter ]
And it's good.
You know?
It does the job,
'cause that anger
has got to go somewhere,
you know?
I want to be nice
during the day,
so I just take all my anger out
on myself in my sleep.
[ Laughter ]
That's what I do.
I start my days.
I'm like, "Good morning!
I love you.
I love meetings.
I love when men talk over me
in meetings.
Yes, I said it first,
but you said it taller."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And then,
at the end of the day, you know,
go home, go to sleep,
put in the night guard,
and just grind it out.
[ Light laughter ]
As soon as I'm asleep, I'm like,
"I will destroy myself
in my rest!"
And then wake up and go,
"Good morning!
I love you.
I have a headache."
It's healthy.
It's wellness.
I do feel so blindsided
by the number
of sleep accessories I require.
It's more than I thought,
you know?
I didn't think I'd grow up
and have to gear up for sleep.
[ Laughter ]
I wish someone had warned me.
I wish when I was a kid, there'd
been a Sleep Disorder Barbie.
You know, just to get
the image in your head, right?
Just to see little girls
being like,
"My Barbie likes melatonin!"
[ Laughter ]
"My Barbie smokes weed
till she's tired."
[ Laughter ]
"Whoa! Ken sleeps
in a separate bedroom!"
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, guys, so much.
I'm Emmy Blotnick.
[ Cheers and applause ]